Brandon is with us in Tyler Texas hi
Brandon welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
better than I deserve what's up four
times through the hole - I'm having
trouble here on you can you speak
directly into your phone please is that
better
a little bit yes sir okay so I'm a
full-time student I have two jobs and I
have a wife and four children I'm just
about to graduate in May and well I'm
just I'm also having trouble also
finding the job because a lot of folks
won't experience but what the phone call
is about my were I'm roughly about
$24,000 in that first student loans I
just started meet my wife just got saved
about two years ago and we're on fire
for the Lord on fire I'm a youth pastor
at my local church and anyways my
wanting to be debt-free and trying to
also have an $8,000 car payment which I
should be able to have that paid off
with my current income in about eight
months but my wife we have four kids one
only at home everyone's there at school
she does not want to work she wants to
be a stay-at-home mom and I wanted to
see what you thought about that but what
the Bible says about that I don't find
the Bible requiring her to work or to
stay at home and I think that's a
decision the two of you make and your
economics look at that there's lots of
scriptures dealing with women and men
being industrious probably the most
famous about ladies would be proverbs 31
and it goes there in great detail the
great industry of the proverbs 31 woman
that she
that she earns an income that she makes
money and she makes her household proud
as well but I don't find scriptures
saying you have to stay home with your
kids I don't find Scripture saying you
have to be in the marketplace and so
either either one so what we do need to
do is work together as a team and
submitting ourselves one to another
scripture says that I mean we're serve
each other and serve our household and
not not it's not selfish desire selfish
ambition it would be what's good for the
family and if you got four children at
home and she can at a minimum
biblically she would be required to be
an expert home economists use that time
at home to cook from scratch which is
much cheaper and and also more healthy
obviously she's a coupon queen you know
that she's looking at consignment sell
clothing and anything she can do a lot
of ladies have great eBay businesses you
know what can she do that's a christy
right kind of a business boutique thing
that they she can do while she's at home
with the kids that actually makes money
and there's lots of things out there
that you can do without quote taking the
nine-to-five career job there's nothing
wrong with a career job so what is your
degree going to be in instrumentation
and electrical okay and what much
working in power plants chemical plants
the maintenance part of the job okay all
right
and so when you land that when you land
that will all your income increased to
roughly about 30 to 40 an hour Wow will
increase a lot of raised my kids by
myself on $10 an hour for the last since
2009 yeah so when you get that job I
don't think we're not to worry much
about her in the income she produces my
wife's been a full-time mom for 33 years
now she's a full-time Mimi and keeper of
the Shih Tzu Rufus and but you know
we're not in a position that we need an
income created from her